[Music]
all right you guys good
so I'm Sammy a little bit about me a
mixed I'm a mix my dad's a man mom's a
woman so half man half woman so you know
the stereotypes I hate asking for
directions but I get lost all the time
I'm actually half Lebanese American
thank you ladies yeah you know what they
say about Lebanese guys um nothing
okay and then I'm half Palestinian so
I'm in the news all the time kind of
family stuff crazy cuz I'm Palestinian
my roommate is Jewish so we're always
fighting over his room starts at my
Nan's
he pays more rent but I've been there
longer
and we look the same but um I'm not
really religious I don't believe in
heaven and hell because hot air rises so
it should be the other way around and I
believe that God is a woman so I don't
say Amen I say that's what she said you
know an open-minded guy I'm from San
Francisco I'm a big supporter of gay
rights just through my friend Tyler
coming-out party it was a surprise party
someone had to tell him you know
surprise what your gay bro we knew it
we popped out of a closet to be ironic
but they recently discovered the gaijin
Wranglers extra-small these are all junk
[Music]
I'm not really a man's man myself though
it's embarrassing like last week I got a
flat tire right next to a homeless man
so I was looking at him for help but
once it was like opposite world he's
like spare change I'm like change spare
I'm trying to drive less though my
friends an environmentalist he's always
complaining he's like the polar bears
have feelings too the polar bears are
just like people when the ice caps melt
where the polar bears gonna go I'm like
come on if bears are just like people
I'm sure the polar bears will be okay
right well no because I figure a little
just take land from the grizzly bears
have the black bears do all the work and
[Applause]
and have the the panda bears building
railroads that's not racist it's just a
bear joke so there's no bear bears make
a country call it America I like to have
polar half black bear president Oh bear
month all right guys
send the koala bears to Australia and
the gummy bears to San Francisco still
America I actually used to teach
American history to kids from the inner
city so I had to come up with analogies
gangster analogies to relate the
material like we were doing American
history of the 1900s I was like all
right the 1900s right imagine you're at
a party you got your French homie and
your British homie right and then a
German dude comes up starts picking on
your homies you like what the hell
so you knock the German dude out pop and
the whole party's like doom now the
party stopped serving alcohol your weed
gets all dry you put all your money on
the dice games and the dice games crash
like oh hell not depression and then
the German dude comes back he starts
picking on your Jewish homie you're like
what the hell but then you get socked in
the back of the head by a Japanese do go
shoot what's going on you take out the
German dude in the Japanese do pop the
whole party's like oh now you see two
Korean twin brothers fighting right ones
in red ones in blue you help out the one
in blue cuz you're a [ __ ] you know I'm
saying and you're like shoot um go
holler at this Vietnamese Ho Chi Minh
right that's her name she meant she's a
ho you lookin good girl she splashes the
orange soda back in your face meanwhile
across the party there's a Russian dude
straight staring you down really cold
the Russian dudes like what you're like
what and nothing ever happens there's an
Iraqi who burning up the rug you chased
him out the party he disappears for 10
years
you give her Somalian homey a sandwich
hook up with a girl named Monica in the
bathroom the party's like I'm your life
my bad and that's the 1900 right there
that's all
brain
[Applause]
so we're gone Sammy okay
[Applause]